[Musique]
la reine Elizabeth est venue à
Versailles en 1957 à l'invitation du
président Coty et c'était c'était un
moment très important ça a été peut-être
la première grande visite d'État de la
prière et elle en avait profité pour
inaugurer l'Opéra Royal de Versailles
qui avait été entièrement entièrement
restauré par Jappy à l'époque et puis
elle résidait aussi non pas à Versailles
même mais dans le domaine au Grand
Trianon à l'époque où le général de
Gaulier élan ayant fait complètement
restauré l'aile de Trianon sous bois
pour y accueillir des chefs d'État le
président Pompidou l'avait installé là
pour un une visite qui était semi privée
semi-officiel le prince Charles qui
maintenant est le roi Charles III
connaît bien le château de Versailles
aussi où il a eu l'occasion évidemment
de venir à plusieurs reprises
le château de Versailles vous savez
c'est un peu la salle des fêtes de la
République c'est ce qu'avait oublié les
présidents Chirac Sarkozy et Hollande
avant eux nombreux ont été les chefs
d'État qui se sont
centices chez eux à Versailles on
raconte toujours une anecdote je ne sais
pas si elle est vraie mais on raconte
que le général de Gaulle un jour vient à
Versailles pour recevoir le Roi Baudouin
et la reine Fabiola il s'installe dans
le petit appartement de jour qui avait
été
aménagé pour lui en attendant l'arrivée
des souverains belges et Madame
vanderchem qui était américaine qui
était l'épouse de Gérald vanderchem lui
dit mon Général sentez-vous chez vous et
il paraît que de Gaulle lui avait
rétorqué du tac au tac mais madame je
suis chez moi et c'est vrai que d'une
certaine manière on doit pouvoir dire
que à Versailles la République est dans
ses meubles
[Musique]
oui alors vous savez j'ai fait un livre
moi là-dessus qui s'appelle le
Versailles après les rois qui racontent
tout ce qui est devenu le château de
Versailles à partir de la Révolution et
jusqu'à nos jours et on se rend compte
que Versailles n'a jamais cessé d'être
au cœur même de toutes les solennités du
pays que l'on soit sous l'Empire que
l'on soit sous la monarchie restaurée
des frères de Louis XVI sous la
Monarchie de Juillet à l'époque de
Louis-Philippe sous le Second Empire
bien sûr puisque c'est notamment qui a
été reçu la reine Victoria et le prince
Albert en 55 et d'ailleurs je crois que
on évoquera cette réception fastueuse de
la reine Victoria à Versailles pendant
la visite du roi Charles III et puis
ensuite bien sûr pendant les différentes
républiques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui oui ça n'a rien à voir avec le
statut de souverain ou non alors c'est
vrai que le général de Gaulle lorsqu'il
a décidé d'utiliser le château de
Versailles pour les grandes solennités
de la République je vous ai parlé du Roi
Baudouin il a reçu également le
président Kennedy avait l'intention de
donner à cette
assez comment dire à ce château à cette
réception particulière à Versailles un
statut
spécifique il voulait d'une certaine
manière honorée particulièrement les
grands hôtes de la France en visite
d'État par la suite le président
Pompidou a plusieurs reprises et surtout
le président Giscard d'Estaing qui a
fait un grand usage de Versailles ont un
peu étendu l'utilisation du château on
se rappelle notamment la très grande
réception qui avait donné le président
Giscard d'Estaing pour le chat d'Iran et
et la chabanoué et Farah Diba et puis il
y a eu donc le sommet de Versailles de
1982 ne l'oublions pas ou le président
Mitterrand a redonné d'une certaine
manière à Versailles une place centrale
puisque le monde entier avait les yeux
rivés sur ce qui à l'époque était la
réunion du G7 avec Ronald Reagan avec
Margaret Thatcher avec toutes les avec
tous les chefs d'État et de gouvernement
de cette époque du début des années 80
et c'est le président Chirac qui
par un républicanisme peut-être mal
placé je n'en sais rien et il semblerait
que ce soit d'ailleurs sur les conseils
de sa fille Claude en tout cas c'est ce
que j'ai entendu dire ça je ne pourrais
pas le prouver c'est lui qui a décidé de
mettre un peu Versailles au rangard pour
répondre à votre question complètement
Patrice c'est vrai que Versailles a été
un lieu très important pour l'histoire
de la République ne serait-ce que parce
que
à partir de 1871 avec les prodromes de
la Commune de Paris le président de
l'exécutif à l'époque le chef de
l'exécutif Adolphe Thiers avait fait
venir l'ensemble des services
gouvernementaux et des corps constitués
à Versailles ainsi que le Parlement
l'assemblée de l'époque l'assemblée des
urnes de février 71 et il avait rapatrié
l'assemblée depuis enfin on disait à
l'époque la chambre depuis Bordeaux
jusqu'à Versailles à partir du moment où
le régime est devenu bicaméral on a
installé le Sénat dans l'ancienne Opéra
royal et pour la Chambre des députés on
a construit le grand hémicycle d'Edmond
Joly dans dans l'aile du Midi et c'est à
ce moment-là évidemment que Versailles
est devenu un lieu parlementaire et ce
qui est amusant intéressant c'est que
des MacMahon les présidents sont rentrés
à l'Élysée les corps constitués sont
revenus à Paris mais les parlementaires
prudents sont restés à Versailles
jusqu'en 1879 ce qui veut dire que au
moment du vote du régime ce qu'on
appelle l'amendement vallon en 1875
c'est bien la Versailles que
l'amendement vallon a été pris donc la
Troisième République ancêtre de la
quatrième et de la 5ème nos républiques
sont nés à Versailles et c'est vrai que
pendant longtemps jusqu'en 1962 tous les
présidents de la République ont été élus
à Versailles y compris je me permets de
le rappeler le général de Gaulle pour
son premier mandat
ça me fait penser à cette très jolie
scène extrait d'un film de Sacha Guitry
qui s'appelle en montant les
Champs-Élysées où l'on voit un certain
nombre d'activistes sur des murs de
Paris écrire à la craie vive le roi
c'est rayé vive la nation c'est rayé
vive l'Empereur et vive le Roi et vive
l'Empereur et un moment Sacha Guitry et
que ça blouse de maître d'école arrive
il efface tout ça il écrit vive la
France il se retourne vers le public et
il dit c'est tellement plus simple